the Joe Rogan experience I don't mind
the fake butts at all the the more
obnoxious the better I'm one of those
guys I don't know what it is you like I
I love it never grab one now if you felt
a frisbee inside someone's ass do you
think you would enjoy it I mean I just
wouldn't touch it that much I would just
stare at it a lot but you would know
that if you touched it you'd feel that
frisbee in there got half a frisbee to
give it some bulk dude is that what it
feels like I don't know I would imagine
there's like a wedge in there it's like
a [ __ ] nerf football in there or
something I think it's like more like
pudding or something like like squishy
you know what it is it's a [ __ ] sign
that you're too lazy to go to the gym go
to the gym it's not hard go do squats
it's not hard the problem is the girls
like Kim Kardashian have set the bar so
high what's that girl's name is E as
legs eeeh what's her name Iggy Azalea
that one
that girl's that girl's butt is
obnoxious
that's not rageous there was a video
with her dancing and it was like
watching someone in a wave pool it was
all just wiggling back and forth well
Jamie what do you think can we see some
of that I haven't seen this before you
could see some wiggle but those girls
have set the bar so high with big butts
you know that you like you have a
regular nice ass like it's not good
enough anymore for a lot of these girls
because you see these yeah but I need to
see some wiggling who is what is that is
that her over the years that's what her
butt used to look like in 2013 and then
she got super addicted to powerlifting
but not with her arms or upper body at
all it all went into her ass ended by
2018 she has this badonkadonk look at
that though isn't that beautiful looks
like she was experimenting with it
earlier though right 2014 just a little
bit yeah just a little bit pretty girl
big ass hmm well look at that upper
right picture look at that see that's
where it's an issue that's what that's
what you find out what it really is not
to me it's not
ohcome on the look it is E as well hi
say your name's eggy eggy see that's sad
to me that doesn't you can get that but
you just have to do squats and if oh
yeah that's so wrong looks like a human
head on there you know McDonough has one
of them now oh really well Madonna
damn someone pull her side and go Hey
look at me
Oh No yeah that real that's right it's
Madonna yeah looking at pull it up
what whoa it looks like she has a bunch
of stuff in her pockets might be a
diaper oh yeah dude I'm telling you
people are doing this and it's do you
know you know what body dysmorphia is
right yeah that's what it is man it's
like when when a woman has double D tits
and she thinks she needs ease
I need ease when a guy's at the gym and
he's [ __ ] 350 pounds he thinks he
looks small people get crazy when people
are anorexic same thing it's body
dysmorphia it's an issue with human
beings we don't see ourselves the way
other people see ourselves thank God
yeah it's the only thing that gets you
through it's just you know people are
[ __ ] envelop if people are vulnerable
[Applause]